the in Rappaport my compadre from the
NFL media group here on the Rich Eisen
show thanks for calling any and so is
Jon Gruden really being offered
ownership by the Oakland Raiders is that
is that really what's happening right
now it is it is something they were
talking about it was something they were
planning to do in their sort of
elaborate pitch to try to make sure that
he doesn't leave them at the altar kind
of like he did the Colts last year they
were thinking about it will it actually
happen I don't know because it's gonna
complicate things a lot you have to have
several levels of approval it will it
does not take five minutes because it's
something that would have to be approved
by an ownership committee and then I
actually believe by the whole big group
so it is complicated well I don't know
if it'll actually come to it I would
assume offering him ten million dollars
and the rights to wear silver and black
for the rest of his life will be enough
but I know they're prepared to do it if
they need to yeah cuz right now the ESPN
says he's going to be in the booth
calling a game against the Raiders
perhaps chief rival in the Chiefs uh
that that that would lead to some
awkward conversations don't you think
yeah
I mean it would lead to a lot of
awkwardness yeah and you know it's funny
I'm never early in the year when when
Greg Olson was gonna do the Vikings game
right I think that's what it was it was
like a big deal like will Greg Olson be
allowed to watch practice and they well
of course he would never be allowed to
watch practice that would be such an
unfair advantage and they didn't allow
him to do it
so now Gruden's gonna come in with his
old buddy Andy Reed who obviously has
been on staff with and our buddy and
he's gonna watch his practice and in
coach against him next year I'll be
curious to see I've tried to find out I
have not gotten clarity on how that's
actually going to work but it's it's
interesting and I mean the fact that
ground you saw this rich but like he
talked to a Bay Area reporter today and
Gruden said I believe on the candidate I
think I'm being considered there's some
fun trolling that's going
right but right now he's he's just
chilling out in the fired football
coach's Association right there in Tampa
Florida where he might be moving out of
shortly in Rappaport here on the Rich
Eisen show if we gotten all the firings
out of the way do you think what there's
still something outstanding in
Cincinnati obviously but tell me what
else here rumbling there and elsewhere
well it seems like Texans are not going
to open I think that's pretty clear from
Bill O'Brien today and the fact that
they're hiring a GM to work with him
which is very important so it's really
about now the Bengals and we're waiting
on Marvin Lewis it's interesting like a
month ago this was basically done both
sides are ready to have a divorce I'm
not so sure it's done yet and the more
people I speak to that are close to
Marvin Louis the more I think he
actually has a chance to stay I know
he's gonna want some things he's gonna
want some blind men he's gonna want some
you know some say so and how they're
gonna proceed but I'm not sure that
one's done just yet and then you know
for me the other one to watch is the
Titans I know they made the playoffs and
usually that's that means everything is
good I am not so sure things are good I
know there's still frustration with
Marcus Miller other than where he's
going so so yeah did you just get an
email or a text
did you just be honest did you just
start reading something important yeah I
did I want to break news here you want
to break news can you break it it's
actually I it's already out there
because Robert Moss we just twitted it
but it's about Mike McCarthy getting a
contract extension it was during the
season the one-year extension okay
during the season so that's and I think
that comes out today because they need
to hire a new GM and the fact that he is
extended through a year makes it
unlikely that they're gonna move on from
Mike right not that they would anyway
but let's be honest here the the number
of GM openings around the league where
you you see the candidates are all
currently in the house of Green Bay
right now there's no way they're gonna
go out a house and hire somebody there
are
right I think they are going to
interview out of house I don't know that
they're gonna hire so the thing is like
if you were gonna do a G I mean we do
this every year we look at these GM
search figure out who's interviewing
half of them come from Green Bay I mean
one of the guys alonzo highsmith is
probably gonna take a job with the
Browns today and John Dorsey his buddy
you got Elliot Wolfe you got Brian
Goethe couldn't you got Russ ball those
are three very good GM candidates in the
building so they're gonna interview
outside have to follow the runing rule
and all that but yeah I would be
surprised if it's not one of their very
very respect to candidates in the
building a few minutes left with Ian
Rapoport on here on the Rich Eisen show
and we're on this show okay so we're not
talking on the NFL Network so let's
let's completely take the let splits
completely take the B I guess filters
off here okay and and let's not be
fact-based for a moment craziest rumor
craziest rumor you're hearing the
splashy esteem that you are hearing that
that people are talking about that might
take a head coaching job in the National
Football League elsewhere if they're
employed by somebody now in college or
currently I mean Courtney give me a good
one give me the juiciest you're here not
even it's not even juicy anymore because
it was put to bed but there were
definitely people interested in Jim
Harbaugh and actually those people
interested in John Harbaugh and I mean I
had people reach out to me from other
teams saying uh other rhythms could move
on from John Harbaugh like no oh okay
alright cool I'm with Y well never mind
okay I could see where that's going you
know I think both hard balls were Adam
and so Jim saying he's definitely
staying in Michigan I'm sure he said
that because he got interest from from a
couple NFL teams and John Harbaugh I
know would be a really strong candidate
if he was ever fired by the Ravens which
he's not going to be right well I mean I
don't they love him he loves them and
and but they have been 500 there for a
few years and and you know ever since
Flacco son that big deal they haven't
been back to the playoffs I mean so but
and and this year they were right there
and just I know
so I guess so Harbaugh Jim Harbaugh is
definitely put to bed
to the pros that's what you're saying as
far as I know I have not heard him
considered for any of the current
openings although there's two ones where
you think you could at least consider
the Colts and the Bears right I know are
the Bears gonna pay what it would take
I don't know that they would mmm and
with the Colts I just I haven't heard
enough to where I think that's actually
real
I have not all right and last one for
you who are you hearing what's the rumor
already now that we've turned into the
calendar year of the draft who the
Browns are looking at a quarterback who
do you think who are you hearing about
you know first blush I need to know if
Sam Donnell is coming out and I know you
know this was considered a done deal in
the Nevada and struggled in the bowl
game and I'm not sure it's a done deal
anymore I I don't I really don't know I
mean I thought it would be him but I
don't even know if he comes out now yet
the Wyoming kids you got the you know
Rosen from UCLA I don't know and I've
talked to all the people close with
Dorsey to try to figure out which way he
would go and nobody will tell me no no
either he knows or
hey you know Brock when we put all these
videos up as you know on our on our
Twitter handle of all of our best of
videos i-17 we got one per I got one
text I got a lot of text from people but
only one talking about our Elizabeth
Shue video do you know what that was
[Laughter]
mmm-hmm that's right is that right if
you had a name one Elizabeth's you movie
would be cocktail not not Karate Kid not
not uh not anything else not adventure
the babies matches babies you know for
me I mean for me it would be Kaka I love
karate kid anyway but cocktail is my
favorite the show animal chat soon or
you might say or you might say Tom
Cruise movie actor yeah it's just take
care of brothers thanks the call thank
you that rap sheet the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience
you